i remember as a kid like uh
there was like this um this i don't know
if it was a beef or a weird energy
between
you boys in chicago and the bone thugs
guys
it was kind of like i think they might
have said something on art of war
yeah i think it was art of war right it
was on that album
like all of the all the the early
early rappers that that had that style
at some
form or or or time
got out their body a little bit right
yeah yeah cause it was like no you bite
me you bite me well
i was doing it first yeah we all got out
of our body a little bit you know about
that type of stuff so that was that was
early on when uh you know we all were
trying to stake claim at a certain vibe
not realizing that we were all the
founders of a certain sound
facts people well you know once we
started to realize how many uh
people we influenced then that's when we
realized that we were all brothers in a
sense who who who said something first
back then like who took the first so you
were the first okay so it was you first
yeah yeah i think i kicked it off first
i think i saw a crazy bone
when we was doing a video for spit your
game
okay yeah i remember yo that's crazy
yeah because years later you guys end up
working on that together
yeah yeah yeah shout out to big man yeah
shout out to crazy
you know all of them are guys though you
know yeah that's dope yeah yeah it's
crazy because we think about like how
rap beef is now it's like it's not a lot
of maturing and getting past it anymore
you know what i'm saying
yeah you know uh and then then there is
some you know so hopefully
hopefully a lot of the younger cats look
at
the way we moved a little bit and kind
of kind of follow suit